this is a production of cornell
university
okay so we've been talking about the
physical aspects of soil
but there's a chemical aspect of soil
that we can test very easily
that is ph which is measures the acidity
or
alkalinity of any substance and in soils
ph determines very much what
nutrients are available to plants so
some plants
can tolerate a wide range of ph and some
have a very narrow range of ph where
they grow well in so we need to know
this in terms of plant selection
the ph test is very simple we use a
cornell ph
kit which is a color metric test
and we'll take we'll try two different
soils there's a
two parts of the kit one is the standard
and one is a wide range we always start
with the standard
so we have these cups where we're going
to put a little bit of soil in one of
the depressions
i'm not going to fill it up just a
little bit of soil
and then we're going to take one of the
reagents here
there are two we always start with
bromothymol blue
which is the neutral range we want to
start with the neutral range and then we
can go up
more alkaline or go down more acid
so using brown thymol blue we're going
to drop drop by drop
until we have a little bit of free
solution
we're going to mix this oh yes
for about 10 to 20 seconds
so that the reagent mixes with the soil
and then we're going to allow that
solution to go down the channel
in this case there's quite a bit of soil
there but i can still see a color
what we're looking for is the color in
the channel
so we use a color chart to determine
what
that ph is saying uh there's reading
and we in this chart it says brom final
blue on the top
so we're going to look at the color we
find
in the channel versus the color chart
i'd say somewhere between 6.0 and 6.2
based on the color of the chart maybe
6.0
okay so if we're at one end of the color
chart we want to go
further because we may not see exactly
what
the final ph would be so in this case
we'll use
another reagent in the kit which goes
from ph
5 to 6.2 it's at the lower end so we
take another bit of soil from our
sample put it in the other bowl
and using chlorophenol red
we're going to wet the sample
and mix it by tapping it
so that the solution bathes the soil in
the
cup
now we're going to allow that
bead to go down the channel
back and forth and we're going to use
the
color chart at the bottom which says
chlorophenyl red
to see what our
color is you can see
we're at the six
to six point two range so in fact the
six point two which we
saw with brampton blue is correct
because we've uh corroborated that with
another
solution so here is six six point two
pretty close so i'd say it's about
six to six point two ph and that would
be the final
determination for this soil now when
we're changing soils and we're going to
do another soil or another sample we
always want to clean our plate with
deionized water so we're not going to
change
use the ph of the tap water to change
our
our reading
so i have another soil here which you
want to test
you can't tell anything about the soil
by looking at it in terms of what the ph
is and that determines
very importantly how much certain
elements are available to
plant roots so we're going to put a
little bit of
soil in the bowl start again with
bromothymol blue
which is the neutral range drop drop
drop
do we have a little bit of free
solution
mixing it with the soil and then getting
a bead down the channel
and here instead of that kind of
yellowish green we have almost a blue
green
color which would be
at the end of the bronzer blue chart
sort of 7.2 but again being that we're
at the end we need to go further
to see if that's the final range of ph
so here we take the wide range test kit
which has goes higher
with phenol red or much lower with brom
crease or green
we're going to go higher with phenol red
because we start stopped at 7.2 we want
to go
up in terms of the seeing what the real
ph
is so here we're going to put some more
soil in the second bowl
by the way you want to have your hands
clean when you do this
so you're not introducing anything into
the sample
so here we're going to take phenol red
which is the wide high range
to see what the soil actually is
and we're going to mix it sometimes you
see the color change when you're mixing
it
and then we're gonna get a bead down the
channel
and what we're looking for is the film
the color film
in this case we use the color chart for
phenol red
which is pretty bright
and here we're seeing we're not up at
seven we're
more toward i'd say
it's quite blue so we're probably at 8.4
or 8.6
so we have a much more alkaline soil
here than we did
in the first sample and that's going to
determine
which plants can grow well in some of
those types of soils
so we need to know that for plant
selection and it's a very simple test
that you can do without any special
equipment
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu